Aujourd’hui, grand ménage de printemps.
Avec la dernière touche, au sens propre et figuré.
Tiens, c’est étrange, quand j’appuie sur
la valve, la bombe refroidit.
Pour comprendre, on va faire une petite expérience.
Quand je comprime de l’air, ça chauffe.
Les molécules qui composent
l’air se rapprochent et s’agitent.
Cette activité génère de l’énergie sous forme de chaleur.
Quand j’appuie sur la valve,
le phénomène inverse se produit
L’air à l’intérieur de la bombe est comprimé.
Au moment où j’appuie sur la valve,
c’est comme si j’ouvrais une porte.
Le gaz à l’intérieur se détend.
Pour s’écarter les unes des autres,
les molécules qui composent l’air puisent
de l’énergie dans leur environnement,
dans le fluide à l’intérieur de la bombe.
Ce qui a pour effet de refroidir le contenu et le contenant et cette « capsule de déconfiné ».
Si vous avez aimé cette capsule,
n’hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez aussi voir ou revoir celles des jours précédents en cliquant sur le côté gauche.
J’en réalise une nouvelle par jour.
Alors pour éviter d’en louper,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche
Allez à demain et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.